from columbia university
uh
who is going to tell us about the
cooperation genetic model for diseases
and others
so hello and it's a pleasure to be here
and like to thank the organizer for the
kind invitation
um so i'll begin with the for the
benefit of the computer science side of
the room i'll begin with a brief
introduction and i apologize in advance
for those who
know the stuff inside out and for some
vulgarizations in order to
get everybody up to speed and another
apologetic initial comment is that i'll
focus on advantage on examples from
humans which is not in any way to
underestimate 100 years of work on other
systems
um
so
shortly after the publication of the
origin of species darwin's cousin
actually francis galton became obsessed
with studying human genetic variation
and he soon discovered that many
phenotypes
appear to be normally distributed high
in in natural population well in human
populations in this case you see the
histogram for height
um and
another observation he made is a about
the relationship between appearance and
offspring or more generally relatives
and this is a
you know a famous plot from galton where
you see the height of the offspring as a
function of the average height of the
parent normalized for males and females
where the size of the points actually
denote the sample size and
this line is just the y equal x which is
what we would expect to see if the
correlation was one between the two and
this is the
the regression line which is lower than
one which led the galton to and others
to develop many
important concepts and coin some terms
you all know like nature versus nurture
regression to the mean
and it took a
quite a while and ronald fisher to come
and explain how these observations could
be in others could be explained in terms
of a mendelian inheritance in the
seminal 1918 paper on the
correlation between relatives and the
supposition of mendelian inheritance
fischer showed that these observations
and others could be explained in terms
of a
simple additive model where i wrote a
version of this model here where we
assume that the phenotype is a has a
genetic and environmental contribution
and more specifically that the genetic
contribution we could break it up into
the contribution across loci and
where here you have the contribution of
the allele from the maternal and
paternal sides and this is the
environmental contribution and if you um
and if you assume that the environmental
contribution
is a normally distributed and that
the
contributions the additive contributions
across loci
uh
that there's many of them and their iid
then you get the normal distribution of
phenotypes in the population where it's
the sum of the additive genetic
contribution and the environmental
contribution um just to give you an
example from humans so this is a these
are a bunch of
a
snips that they that were found to be
associated with height the top 20 snips
say for height with their effect sizes
in males and females normalize them in
some way the typical effect here is two
millimeters just to give you a sense
and
in here what you see is the number of
tall alleles which ranges between 0 and
40 because we have 20 loci and the 20 by
lily closer in this case and here is uh
you know the histogram the percent of
the sample with different number of
alleles
in in here is
the a relationship between the number of
tall alleles and the
the height difference again with
normalization and it appears to be
approximately linear this is of course
not the rigorous test of the additive
model but at least it
corresponds with its predictions um
a second thing you could do with this
additive model is you could define a
heritability as the fraction of variance
that is explained by the additive
genetic contribution
and um once you do that
fischer showed that the you know in this
specific case you could show that the
slope
in this in this
in this
figure is a
simply the this heritability and they
more generally derive the relationship
between between pairs of relatives of
different of different relationships
now
um you could measure it abilities
until recently according to correlation
between relatives and twin studies and
so on now there's perhaps better ways to
do that and the the the surprising thing
is that heritabilities tend to be
extremely high for a wide variety of
traits typically between 10 and 90
percent where here you see some examples
for humans and specifically european
populations and here you see some
examples from
other systems there's also some patterns
that emerge that i won't go into you see
here the morphological and fitness
traits show different patterns
we don't we don't have a good
explanation
for this neither do we have a good
explanation for why heritabilities are
typically so high or why there's so much
a quantitative genetic variation
um
now how do we go about finding the
variance a moment ago i showed you some
variance for height so one way you could
go about it which i'll focus on today is
a is a genome-wide association study
which owing to massive efforts over the
last decade it led to the discovery of
around 10 000 variants corresponding to
hundreds of traits including the
susceptibility to various complex
diseases and the basic idea at least is
very simple where
you you a
take a large sample of individuals you
phenotype them for example you measure
their height and then you genotype them
at many variable sites and at each site
you look at the three
genotypes and
at that relationship to the trait value
and then you do a regression
and the slope gives you the effect size
on the trait and then you get a p-value
and you need to correct for a
you need to adjust for false discovery
rate so you use these p-values this is
how it's usually represented in terms of
a manhattan plot where this is the log p
value and this is just the chromosomes
of the human genome with each point here
corresponding to a p-value for a given
sniff and this is the threshold for
genomic significance in this case and
you see a significant
association
so
um just to give you continue with the
examples of heights so the giant
consortium
did this you know of course with some
statistical sophistication for more than
180 000 individuals genotyping more than
2 million snips for each individual and
discovering 180a
associations loci associated with height
where here these associations are
represented in terms of the minor allele
frequency for
for this snip and here is the effect
size and this line correspond to some
level of power to discover this in the
association study so you get these kind
of scatter plots in the in a little
frequency and effect size
and
yeah
no no this is this plot is all the these
points are all the genome-wide
significant snips to come out of this
association study so each point is a
single snip that turned out to be a
significant association
um
we'll get to that
give me a one minute so okay so yeah so
obviously there's there's limited power
and indeed when when you look at you you
could estimate how much of the heritable
uh variance and height do these
associations explain in the hatches is
despite discovering 180a
associations that this explains only ten
percent of the heritable variation and
this is the you know the well-known from
recent years a missing irritability
problem
um
so
now we get to define genetic
architecture at least the way i'm going
to use it in this talk and in the
genetic architecture is usually defined
in this field in terms of the number of
all the variants in the populations not
only those that we discovered in the
association study in the joint
distribution of their frequency and
effect size
okay so that's a definition i would use
of course in a given
in as lee pointed out in the given
association studies you have a power
limitations uh but you could still begin
to compare architectures okay
among traits so you could look at the
discovered a number you could look you
could compare the distributions you need
to be mindful of the power and the study
design but but
and you could compare the how much of
the heritability was explained for
different rates so you could begin to
look at differences between the
architecture of different traits and
here are some examples
where here is the example of height that
we've seen before below is an example of
a body mass index
and here is an example of schizophrenia
where you just note that given in this
case we're talking about
the probability of developing the
disease then the effect size here
actually corresponds to the log odds
ratio that was found in the study which
is
the equivalent of the additive effect
size for the simplest model for a
disease susceptibility and when you look
at these plots you could already begin
to see some differences so for example
if you compare height and bmi and i note
here that bmi is actually a larger study
at least in terms of the sample size
then
then you see that much less heritability
was explained in bmi as compared to
height
and there's a much fewer variance and
you could also look at the joint
distribution and begin to compare it and
you see that at least for schizophrenia
that that this a joint distribution
appears to be
to follow kind of tightly around the
power line whereas for height it still
follows it but there's a bit more of a
spread
and for for bmi
um
it follows us even even less so where
specifically we have these variants
which are at high frequency and large
effect size
so this this leads to a number of uh a a
number of questions so so one question
is we would like to know how a genetic
and population genetic processes shape
the
genetic architecture of a a very a
variation in in quantitative traits for
example we would like to know whether we
expect to see a different architecture
and how for early onset severe diseases
or for anthropomorphic traits
um
another thing which is of practical
import is if we have some idea of how
that behave perhaps we'll be able to
predict or
inform
the
these study designs for example how much
would you expect to gain in terms of
explained irritability a number of
variants if you increase the study of
your genome association study two-fold
and it also relates to
very basic questions that came up a few
times during this meeting which has to
do with the fact that you know despite
most phenotypes we care about being
quantitative we still
um
know little about the processes that
shape them so maybe we could rely on
these dynamite association studies to do
some inference and learn something about
these processes and underlying
parameters
and and
last but not least in this list if we
think about if a lot of phenotypes that
evolution cares about are quantitative
and there's a lot of variation you would
expect that when
the environment changes then the
selection response would come
primarily from this say from the genetic
variation in order to understand these
processes of that have been recently
called polygenic adaptation then you
i think you need to know something about
the architecture so i'm actually going
to talk only
so mainly on the first question and i'm
going to touch upon the second and third
and
um
and this is also the point to say that
this is work very much in progress
um
so just to give some basic intuition to
begin to model these questions so if we
think about the joint distribution of
frequencies and effect sizes so by and
large we can think of the frequency of
alleles to be determined by selection
and drift so here you see the frequency
spectrum for different uh scaled
selection coefficients and now for
architecture we want to know how
these frequencies relate to effect sizes
on our trait of interest so we could
think generally about a a two extremes
one is a case where the selection
coefficient is independent of the effect
size so how could this happen this
means that our trait does not have
a substantial effect on fitness however
individual variants could affect other
phenotypes and therefore have selection
on them in this case if we look at
different effect sizes then we expect to
see the same frequency spectrum um
the other extreme example is if we have
a phenotype
that actually is the main source of
selection on on on the variants that
contribute
that contribute to it um
and in in that case the effect size will
determine the selection coefficient and
you expect to see a strong relationship
between the effect size and the trait
and the frequency in which you find the
um
the
the allele so
just to give you you know some some
examples so perhaps one could argue that
if you think about a early onset
diseases that are severe or diseases
that affect fertility then maybe they're
closer to a to this extreme of
determining the selection on the
variance and if you think as
anthropomorphic traits maybe height or
bmi maybe they're closer to the
pleotropic extreme that that
i just mentioned here so so this gives
us an idea that that the the the
selection coefficients on variance and
the degree of cleotrophy are important
determinants of a
genetic architecture so now we could go
ahead and try to model this and i'm just
wrote down some requirements we would
like to have in this model so we would
have to have be able to have some
parameter for the degree of cleotrophy
it would be nice if if the pleography
will actually come from a description of
some multi-dimensional phenotype so we
understand where it comes from it would
also be nice if the selection will come
from this multi-dimensional phenotype as
well and of course it it's kind of nice
if you actually know how to solve for
things you care about in this model so
um
lucky enough
fischer developed a model that fits the
bill for some of these things even
though it was for different purposes and
this is a fischer's geometric model
where you consider
a where the space is an n-dimensional
euclidean space where each dimension
corresponds to a different trait or a
different phenotype so individual is
just a point or a vector in this
n-dimensional
space where when we're going to look at
this model we're going to focus on one
dimension on the projection on one
phenotype
but the the the dimension of the space
will be a parameter for pleotropy
okay
um
now we could define the fitness in this
model so
fitness in this model is defined to be
a a
the optimum is at the origin and and the
fitness declines as you move away from
the optimum specifically we're going to
use for analytical reasons they say
gaussian form where here this w a
actually quantifies the strength of
selection when w is strong is a smaller
than selection is stronger and i'll just
note that even though this is a specific
form as long as the population is tight
around this optimum which will end up
being the case then this model would be
equivalent to any model that has a
quadratic form around this say optimum
um
and
okay now we'll introduce some population
genetics into it so so first we'll
introduce mutation so we're going to
assume an infinite science model which
mainly means that
mutations are introduced at some poisson
rate per individual per generation and
and mutations never
occur at the same site so we're
neglecting multiple mutations at the
same site
um
now for mutations we're going to assume
that the mutation is the the effect of
the mutation on the phenotypes is a
vector in this in-dimensional space that
just describes the effect on the
its projection describes its effect on
the different phenotypes
and and we're going to assume that the
the the size of these mutations come
from come from some distribution and
their direction is just isotropic in
this space so closing randomly in all
directions
and
lastly we're going to do the standard
write fischer sampling with viability a
selection mutation for your combination
and so on so it's essentially the
standard model and
just let me tell you how the genotype is
related to the phenotype in this model
so we so if we have a in in
a in individuals
a
phenotype i didn't note by the way i
should note as an aside i forgot to note
that the reason we don't have the
environmental contribution is that it
could actually be swallowed into the
selection parameter so in any way you so
so you have a in individual phenotype
and you could break it up into the
contribution of fixed
sites and the contribution of
segregating sites now for the
segregating site so if we look at the um
contribution to the phenotype from
segregating sites where the i denote the
individual
then we we because of the infinite sites
model each segregating site is bialic
so so what we do is we just sum over the
additive
a contributions where this g-i-a-l is
just the genotype at locus l which could
take a value zero one or two and you
could think of a as the derived
mutation at this site so it's a simple
additive model what we're going to do
for the fixed contribution is that in
our model occasionally a mutation is
going to fix and we're just going to do
bookkeeping so we're going to update the
fitness
component
sorry the the pheno the phenotype that
comes from fixed sites
um
okay so this is the basic model and
in this the dimension of the
fear that space someone's gone away
no no because
these are vectors
uh okay each of those is the vector in
this n-dimensional space
yeah it's still additive it's just
additive in the in the end dimensional
euclidean space um
so
okay so so this model fits some of our
requirements we have a variable degree
of pleotropy which is a the dimension uh
we have a cleotrophy arises from from
the multiple phenotypes from the
different
dimensions that we have and selection
results from how the selection acts on
the phenotype namely wanting to be at
the origin in this dimensional space so
now it would be nice if we could
actually calculate something and despite
the fact that this is a
quite a baroque model it turns out it's
actually it behaves rather simply
so under sensible conditions about the
mutation rate namely that it's high
enough such that it would be a
quantitative trait that many lucid would
segregate but it won't be
too high such that you would have
multiple mutations affecting the trait
to rise in a single individual and a
single generation so under these
conditions it turns out that um if we
look at the distribution of phenotypes
in the population at steady state then
that's described
by a tight normal distribution around
the optimum
okay
so we're we're specifically the the um
the variance
of of that distribution is much smaller
than the uh than the selection
coefficient
and so why is this the case just to give
you a simple intuition so
the fact that this is normal shouldn't
be surprising because we have an
additive model for
for a the genetic variant so if we
assume that you know the fixed component
is the same for the whole population and
the segregating component is a
contribution is is a
sum over iid contributions at many sites
so that gives you the normality
perhaps more interesting is why is it
tight around the optimum and the reason
for that is that this system turns out
to be equivalent to
the population mean is equivalent to a
ball connected to a string where the
string is connected to the optimum but
but you have these it's in a thermal
environment you have these particles
actually hitting it so so the
the the spring is equivalent to
selection the more displacement you have
the stronger selection becomes so you
can't wander very far away and these a
fluctuations correspond to
mutations in drift and it turns out that
this is actually not a metaphor this is
actually a precise analogy and and you
could actually calculate the variance in
in the population mean and that turns
out to be small as long as the dimension
is much smaller than the population size
so you could assume that you're tightly
around this optimum
now
now let's consider an individual allele
because we're interested
we're interested that say in the
segregating site we're interested in a
variance so let's consider a mutation
that has effect size a which that's a
vector and the frequency q in the
population
and given that we know the distribution
of phenotypes in the population we could
now look at the distribution of
backgrounds so i i
i focus at
at this particular locus and then i look
at all the contributions in the
background what their what their
distribution is and i know that the
background plus the contribution of this
locus needs to be normally distributed
around the origin so that gives me the
distribution of backgrounds once i have
the distribution of backgrounds what i
could do is i could calculate the
fitness of each of the three genotypes
in this locus what i do is just i take
the fitness of the three genotypes but
for that i need to know the background
but i integrate over the
contribution of the background and once
i do that
then i could calculate the first two
moments of change in allele frequency in
a single generation
so
the first moment is a is shown here and
the second moment is the i'll get to
that in a moment and the second moment
is just a standard second moment under
a
genetic drift and and once you have the
first two moments of changing a little
frequency in a single generation then
you could use a you know the diffusion
equation in order to get at least the
closed integral forms for anything you'd
like to calculate in this model
so okay so we can solve for things now
before before we start solving for
things let's let's focus a second on the
first moment because there's some
interesting things about it so if you
look at the form of the second moment
you see that this is you know if you
just put the parameter a s over 2 here
this is just the standard
form for the viability selection model
with under dominance
okay so what this means is that
frequency half at the site is an
unstable fixed point and essentially a
the rare allele is always pushed towards
extinction in in in this case
and now the reason isn't a heterozygous
disadvantage like in the standard
viability selection because you know
heterozygous disadvantage doesn't even
mean anything in this model the the
reason is because the population is
tightly centered around the mean
then
a then in
the individual then the allele frequency
at the at the given locus is actually
selected to a reduce the variance that
it contributes to the phenotype so
you're trying to reduce the variance
that that this allele is contributed to
contributing to the phenotypic variance
which is just in this model half times
the
the mutations i squared times pq and
this variance is maximized at half and
minimized towards the end so selection
to reduce the variance just pushes this
towards the ends so this is why
you get this
under a dominant form it also suggests
that it's a probably a more general
property of a of a of many of these of
many of these stabilizing selection
models this was by the way shown for the
one-dimensional case by robertson 61.
um another thing that's interesting here
is that it actually relates a selection
with the size of the mutation because
you see the role of the selection
coefficient is just played by this a
squared divided by w square so this is
the
what plays
this is the selection coefficient here
um so the size of the mutation in the
n-dimensional space is
directly related to our selection
coefficient and specifically if you we
could it tells us we could use natural
units of 2n times this which is just the
scaled selection coefficient
so so we have kind of like intuitive
units for for what goes on here
so now let's go to the kind of things
that we care about uh or at least
you know that that they motivated this
model
um
so
if you recall
in the beginning i told you that the
relationship between selection
coefficient and effect size at our focal
trait at the one dimension is good is
likely going to be crucial for
determining the genetic architecture so
turns out we could actually calculate
what this correlation would be under
this model
and this is the form you get where n is
the dimension of the space and this is
the coefficient of variance of the
distribution of selection coefficients
or mutation sizes as i said a moment ago
and so at least with respect to
pliotropy this
fits our intuition so when the dimension
is one then this correlation becomes one
okay the definition of selection
coefficient in this model is the
apparent selection coefficient yeah it's
it's exactly it's a it's equivalent this
is this is just this a square over two w
a square
okay so what i call selecting
coefficient is just a
is is is just this
this a square where a here is the norm
in the n-dimensional space
divided by
by two w square which was this the
selection parameter in the model
is that
this okay is just coming from the
distribution of the of the distances
from the peak yeah
yeah yeah so you yeah it turns out to
simplify quite nicely in this case and
so so we see that when there's one
dimension nucleotrophy this term becomes
zero and the correlation is one you see
that when you increase the dimension the
correlation goes down but perhaps a bit
surprising at least the first side is
the fact that even when you take the
dimension the cleotrophy to infinity the
correlation doesn't necessarily go to
zero
and and what you have is a term that
depends on the coefficient of variance
of selection coefficients now upon upon
second thought this is not that
surprising because if you have um a peak
distribution like a delta function the
distribution of selection coefficients
then actually the size of the mutation
or the selection coefficients tells you
nothing about the projection on the
trait you're looking at only the
direction determines this projection
however if you have so so in that case
say
the correlation will be zero however if
you have a y distribution of selection
coefficients then larger mutations will
actually tend to have larger projections
on the trait you care about so so
therefore you would still maintain some
correlation between selection
coefficient and effect size and here you
see an example of this a correlation
as a function of a number of traits and
different
coefficients of variation for the
distribution of selection coefficients
so
now we could go a and look at what we
looked before namely what's what's the
relation as a function of these two
dimensions so here i increase the
dimension of the space the triotropy
here i increase the
the wideness of the distribution of
selection coefficient the coefficient of
variation and in a one-dimensional model
then the relationship between the effect
size and the trait and the frequency
is the same
does not depend on the coefficient of
variation in in the one-dimensional case
because the the size of the mutation is
exactly the size of the effect in one
dimension
however when
um when when you move to
a a larger that when you increase the
pleotropy when you increase the
dimension then then you see that there's
less of a relationship you know the
relationship is weaker between the
effect sizes
and the distribu in the frequency
spectrum and then when when when you
move to narrower distributions of
selection coefficient it becomes even
the relationship becomes even weaker so
this is a you know what we saw at the
beginning and then one thing you could
do is you could you know you could
simulate an association study in this
model so in this case uh we simulated an
association study with
the same parameters where
but we we adjusted things such that
in
a for study size of 10 000
the discovered variance in all these
four cases would be the same and then we
also adjusted the target size how many
mutations affect the trait such that
we'll discover the same number of
variants
in this case so this is the power that
of course this corresponds to power half
in a study size of ten thousand and in
this corresponds to a study size of five
thousand and forty thousand just to
to um
give you a sense of what's going on here
um but more informative than you know
just looking at these scatter plots is
actually to look at the density of
variance
that comes from different combinations
of effect size in the in the frequency
so when here the different shades of
blue correspond to the regions that
account for
20 of the variants 40 percent and so on
up to 95
and if we start for the peaked case with
the one dimension then you see that
there's a obviously in this case there's
a narrow distribu distribution of a
effect sizes
um
and to understand the distribution along
the frequencies
i i just note that if if our if our if
we were in neutrality then the
contribution to variance just ends up to
be the same at all frequencies because
we have weak selection here then we
actually have more density towards the
lower frequencies so this explains the
shape of the density here
now then when we move to uh higher
dimension increase the pleiotropy what
we get is we get this widening of the of
the distribution of effect size on our
on our focal trade and importantly we
also get a a lot of variants that have
very low effect sizes
and or low frequencies which by the way
would be very difficult to capture in a
genome-wide association study and all
the more so when you move
to the case
where the distribution of selection
coefficient is actually a wider so this
begins to tell you and how these
different parameters would affect a
our discovery in in in uh genome-wide
association studies so so here what i
have is the is the
expected explained variance and percents
as a function of study size for these
choices of parameters and what you see
that happens is for for the case where
you have nucleotrophy one dimension and
the very peak distribution of selection
coefficient what's going to happen is
until a certain study size you won't
discover anything in this case around 3
000. but then once you discover the
first variance you're very quickly going
to discover all the variants when you
increase your study size
when you move to the other extreme which
is the y distribution with a a lot of
cleotropy then you're going to discover
things with much lower sample sizes but
you'll have to go on increasing your
sample size a lot in order to get to the
tail of these things that have low
effect sizes and or lower frequencies
so
this tells us something about how these
parameters would affect
you know how successful we expect to be
in genome-wide association studies now
of course you would like to do this um
for
for
you know the real traits you would like
to
you know one thing you would like to do
is you would like to do a
inference of these parameters based on
what you see from
from genome-wide association studies and
then maybe you could say you know the
caveats of the assumptions of the model
and so on maybe you could say something
about what you expect to see if you
increase your sample size and how that's
expected to vary in different traits um
take what i'm about to say with a huge
grade of salt but i recently heard that
for a schizophrenia they they're
the consortium is about to publish a
huge study
in
where um
now by increasing the sample size but
they they manage to discover hundreds
hundreds of variants and that kind of
fits
vaguely though you would like to do this
more rigorously to where is
schizophrenia fits in our a two
dimensional a parameter space in terms
of
kind of
following a tightly the the power
relation but you know of course you need
to do this rigorously
another thing you could do with these
kind of interests a propose inform you
know
get some information about what
evolutionary parameters are
perhaps shaping the variation here now
we're working on it i'm not ready to
show any results on that i could just
show you the basic idea of how we're
going about doing the inference and and
the basic idea is just that you could
write down the likelihood of the model
parameters here which is the target size
for for for this a trait some parameters
of the distribution of selection
coefficients
and the dimension in this specific model
and then you could write down this
likely this function of the discovered
variance
the uh the
the missing irritability that you didn't
discover that's an important input here
and also of course the study design how
big was the study for example that's
that's quite important here
and a
say and what you get when you write down
this likelihood then then you you know
you just get the product of the
probability of having a variant with a
particular effect size and frequency
times the power to detect this variance
and then there's
a term for not explaining a certain
fraction of the variance
so
what happened to the prior probabilities
of the parameters in the model
um
so
what we're doing is just maximum
likelihood so it's equivalent to
assuming a uniform prior i guess um
what was k
here
um
uh i don't remember
well kkk i guess is what's discovered in
the study why we put subscript k here i
don't remember at the moment
that's just you know this is the total
genetic variance and the trait minus the
variance that you were
that you discovered the number of
purposes
what i think i think it's the number of
variants you say are associated with oh
yeah yeah yeah you're right this is the
k here so it's just what's explained by
by the k associations you found
okay
um
so
okay so uh a brief summary so we solve
the model that i hope is intuitive for
how cleotrophy and distribution of
selection coefficients affect
architecture
now of course you'd like to ask
about other models for architecture so
even you can imagine many other models
in the case of
even in the case of stabilizing
selection and and i think some of the
things about these solutions will remain
the same some maybe remain qualitatively
the same so for example
you aim you know the under dominance
is likely to be quite a result quality
being tightly around the
optimum is is probably a
strong quality i think you could use
this type of
approach that it is so complicated to
solve if you write down other
other models um and regarding the
qualitative you know the results that i
showed you of how things vary with
pleotropy and the distribution of
selection coefficients so there were
still grappling was trying to understand
you know to what extent the the you know
how this would change if we change
specific assumptions of the model
needless to say there's other there's
also other models for how
you get a quantitative genetic variation
in a trait so one is a
you know a parent stabilizing selection
maybe the trait that we're talking about
has no effect of fitness at all but the
variants themselves have cleotropic
effects on other traits which are
selected for so one needs to look at
that and then there's also examples of
model models of balancing selection that
reflect some trade-offs and there's
definitely some human traits
for example traits
related to autoimmune diseases for
example that seem to be
perhaps a some balance between you know
humans you move to more dense areas the
pathogen load increases you want it to
increase the activation of your immune
system but then you suffer from
autoimmune diseases for example you know
this is a just a hand waving so these
are other types of models one would want
to look at and inference as i told you
or hopefully i'll be able to say
something
soon enough about that
and um apologetic adaptation i just
don't want to go over time so if you
have
if you ask me about it i'll tell you
what
why i think the question of architecture
is related to understanding polygenic
adaptation so let me just finish by
thanking
the collaborators on this work so you've
all simon's student
no relation i am a student in my lab
who did really the heavy lifting of the
simulations and a lot of the analytical
work here kevin beloy formerly at the
university of chicago who was involved
in the beginning of this work and now
moved to pursue other passions of his
and dick hudson with who
just made us say smarter than we are
so that's all thank you
can you say something about mologenic
please
thank you
um
so i'll just give a
hand waving argument so just to put this
in context so say a you know a
small a population of humans leaves
africa and goes
to live in much colder places okay and
now you want a different ratio of
surface area to volume according to the
allen bergman rule or some other
rule like that and obviously you know
because there's a lot of natural
variation in in in
phenotypes like that then it's likely at
least that
the fast
response of selection would be
out of this natural variation
but then if you want to ask about the
basis of adaptation to such a
shift in in selection pressures then you
want to know for example
where where is the response going to
come from where it's going to where is
it where's the action going to be is it
going to be from weakly selected sites
that because they were
they have small effect sizes they they
were
they were segregating at high population
frequencies and and and then they were
responsible for the shift when when you
moved or are there going to be the
strongly selected things which which are
at lower frequencies but have a bigger
effect on the trade for example that's
one type of question now obviously
as i just talked about the relationship
between the frequency they're going to
be in before the shift in the
environment and the effect size and the
trade depends on pleotropy so in order
to
understand how that's going to work so
here's a
figure from a
a paper by d vlader
and nick here which kind of like gives
you a qualitative picture i think a good
initial way of thinking about the you
know what would happen so here what we
have is a we have some
some quantitative trait
where it was in the optimal value before
we change the environment at time zero
and then a shift to uh shifts to a
different optimum and then what happens
here you see what happens to allele
frequency so at the beginning a lot
those with the right direction go up
very quickly in order to match the new
population mean so here you see what
happens to the to the trait mean it very
quickly matches the new optimum
however they rise to a certain frequency
they match the mean very quickly now
some of them continue all the way to
fixation but that's probably a minority
but in order to balance their effect the
other ones go down back to uh
you know their steady state probability
and this is why we see this transient
effect on the variance in the in the
quantitative trade so at the beginning
the variance goes up a lot and then
selection effectively reduces the
variance but but if you want to know
which which of these
variants you know what effect sizes what
selection coefficients are going to have
him are the ones to go all the way up
statistically speaking then i think you
need to know something about
architecture
and of course that would affect
other things like what type do we expect
to see um what type of signatures of
linked selection of sweeps we expect to
see when you have a shift like that and
maybe a lot of human populations are
actually
that moved around are actually now in
this transient state over here which is
why we don't see
a a lot of high fst
a
in snips in the human genome so
but i think that forget about it this is
at least how we got to study this
question to begin with is we were trying
to do simulations of this and we
realized that we need to know something
about architecture in order to go about
this question
so
so
so when this sort of stochastic theory
was developed it was based on really the
idea of an arbitrary relation between
selection and a linear effect
and what you're saying is well if we
take vicious geometrical or statements
seriously then that predicts a
particular relationship
so you could phrase the question a
different way and say what what could we
observe in data to show whether the
joint distribution of effect sizes and
selection coefficients or minority
frequency what what would that tell us
about whether the stakeholders actually
supports them i have no idea whether it
makes sense to think of these fictional
traits you know we're making like a
high-dimensional quadratic space i i
totally agree i think you know we need
to get started somewhere and you know as
you know
probably better than anyone there's been
you know i don't know maybe 80 years of
work in evolutionary quantitative
genetics trying to get at these
questions
primarily get at the question of why
there's so much quantitative genetic
variation
um but there's been very little work
with this you know with this twist of
trying to understand you know how it
would affect architecture
um so this is definitely a starting
point and you would like to know
first within within models of
stabilizing selection how much things
would be sensitive to changing the
assumptions of the model so you could
use the kind of models that
kitty and hill used for example of some
y-sharp distribution
um and and other kind of things so and
you just want to understand how
the observations would be sensitive to
it how how your qualitative results
would remain in where the process of
doing that and i you know i agree this
is one model it's definitely a toy model
you know we don't think that
phenotypes behave like an n-dimensional
cartesian space and there's other
assumptions that go in here
what we like about this model as a
starting point is that you know you kind
of like intuitive we understand what
cryotherapy means
what selection acting on and
so on
so another comment about the inference
side you could argue that you're doing
anything completely the wrong way um by
by focusing on those in the outlying
tale that have been ascertained so you
could say well what you're predicting is
the distribution of minority frequency
and effect sizes um but it's the bulk of
the distribution matters and there's
kind of funny things going on that are
likely to be especially affecting the
tail which is what we see so you you
could say we want to make it based on
the mold data
so so i agree you know i think when you
do inference uh
this kind of population genetic
inference in general
um you know when you're
you know trying to infer the
distribution of a
selection coefficients on amino acids
for example then then you have the
problem that if you assume some
parametric form and if the data you have
is a kind of like highlighting a
specific part of your parameter regime
then what gives you the ability to infer
what happens in other private regimes is
just the supposition of your of your
parametric form and and and i agree that
this is definitely an issue we're going
to fo we focus here on the things that
we have power to discover um
and and and therefore for example i
would be hesitant you know it kind of
like depends you would like to try
different distributions with that
keep cop out but but i guess i'd be more
inclined uh
you know assuming that robustness works
out and so on to believe inferences that
have to do with what happened if you're
gonna you know double your
sample size and clean wide association
studies as compared to inferences that
have to do with how much of the variance
has to do with rare variants for example
exactly because you're kind of like you
know extrapolating based on a different
region in the parameter space so i
totally agree with
that's a serious issue to contend with
last question there's a slide you had
where you were predicting these curves
as your increased sulfur solids
yeah whoops just one before yeah yeah so
just this is description you'll
strategize for a hundred thousand but
you found all the variants but we've
already found two sets of variants so
all your different models are predicting
that
yeah but this is just uh you know this
is an illustration figure you know i
chose specific parameters to
to generate this uh you know this two by
two of the studies yeah i i could easily
choose different parameters that you
know you wouldn't find a lot in a
hundred thousand and what so do you have
there's a few things you could do one
one
one rather
a yeah so so in terms of the
so i i think you know essentially if you
vary these parameters such as the
um
you know the degree of a
cliotropy the width of the distribution
of selection coefficients and also where
the where the mode of that distribution
is
then you could
pretty much get with a given sample size
um
whatever you want
and in terms of number of variants and
that you you just
you just change the target size so that
would change the fraction discovery that
would change the number of variants you
would discover
it would change it maybe it would change
the fraction a little bit but not the
last possibly because these curves are
very robust if you made
ten thousand extrapolations
you're still not getting near the real
regime
so something else is sparing it's not
just yeah yeah but i think you you know
if you make for example if you make this
wider then i think it's going to change
things quite around dramatically and and
if you were you know at the moment i'm
assuming the two and s of three if you
see the two and s of
you know
four i'm assuming you're already going
to discover much less of the variance
in
so this is just an illustration and not
necessarily as i said it's work in
progress where you'd like to use
different parameters to illustrate this
dependence so it's very qualitative let
me show you here
more questions
thanks